[Music]
murray is in gettysburg pennsylvania hi
murray welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi dr john i appreciate you guys
helping me with my question today sure
what's up so i have uh
my best friend growing up he grew up
here with me in pennsylvania he moved to
california he's been in there for a few
years um he is getting very soon which
is very exciting um naturally i'm the
i'm the best fan so i'm pulling together
the bachelor pardon for him out there
um it's going to be kind of close to la
so it's pretty expensive i'm of course
as the best man i'm covering
all the parts for him uh yeah for the
groom but uh i have i have rented an
airbnb there um which is pretty
expensive uh a month ago i've got i got
everybody saying that you know like the
one i chose was a good option um it was
a lot this was the last weekend in may
like right before memorial day uh yeah
we just i just managed to book it i did
front the money for it and uh today i
thought like you know i haven't had
anyone pay yet for it and uh today i had
someone reach out to one of his friends
from california saying like well i kind
of live close anyway i'll come hang out
with you guys uh but i won't stay the
night so therefore i won't have to like
you know pay my part for the airbnb and
now his other friend who's out there
like i don't know if he's collaborating
but he's kind of given the same kind of
messages but hasn't what he said he
hasn't like really decided yet um
so i i'm just kind of wondering like do
i just kind of like eat the cost for
their portions how much is the money
it's it's it worked out to be about two
hundred dollars a person including the
groom so i'm covering his so the total
out of pocket for you the total to rent
the airbnb was how much
um it was like around 800 bucks yeah
what do you make a year
so i i do have plenty of money to cover
it's not a money not really as much of a
money issue um like we together my wife
and i make a little over 150 because
that's that's not a problem dude listen
just eat it eat it and go on your life
enjoy the wedding
i mean i just i mean i don't know how
people are like comfortable with not
like with owing
people stuff i i don't know i i think i
just need to get over it and just
realize they're hate friends and or
cancel it cancel it man
or tell them they can't come if they
don't pay i mean you're running the show
here i i'm just gonna lean into dave
push back i i'm just going to lean into
what
i'm not going to carry other people's
stress and if i'm going to go to the
wedding anyway and i'm going to plan for
a good evening
it stinks man but it
is what it is
you know i i might
the most i would ever do is maybe one
message back and i would just say
you know i i booked this based on each
of everyone paying their part it's
disappointing that you won't but
whatever yeah
and just i would shame them a little
yeah here's my venmo okay like here's my
venmo and then dude i'm not going to
give it another second thought yeah yes
it stinks it's the worst blah blah blah
yeah you've already stressed more than
800 bucks over it yeah and you and you
guys are thinking the same thing even
like because i'll be drinking and stuff
that night and like you know not not
crazy or anything i'm like 30 but you
know how that is but uh like i know some
30 year olds that can still get after it
now but yeah i might say hey uh i'm
going to cover this or yeah i mean
here's the thing make peace with what
you want to do you're trying to make
everybody happy here and at the same
time you have this need that you want
met which is everybody contributing
their fair part and at some point you
have to run up against that fantasy and
say that's not happening
and so okay what's the picture of the
party that i was asked by the groom to
throw and i'm going to lean into that
and
i get to decide who's there and who's
not and i mean you get to make all these
calls make the decisions just move on
with your life you're not going to make
everybody happy and have everybody give
like meet all your needs to
yeah i think i think between her and i
we were like disappointed about
everything but we were kind of i think
we were kind of leaning towards just
like whatever happens happens like i'm i
won't i don't want to ruin the groom's
time by like telling people they can't
come or they can't spend the night
one of them's gonna be full of capri
suns and one of them's gonna be full of
really nice drinks
okay that's what i would do and there's
gonna be like four hot dogs and then
there's gonna be catered food for those
who paid mignon
in hot dogs right i mean you can have
some fun with it man just like dave dave
said
all this is a soul tax
that 800 you've you've put in eight more
than 800 worth of worry when it comes to
the balance on your net worth let it
ride man yeah i i probably if it was my
buddies or
these aren't actually your buddies
they're friends of the groom that are
being twerps they're not your friends uh
i probably just send them a note and say
hey i booked this
on the idea that everybody was going to
pay their fair share if you don't want
to
i'm more concerned about the groom's
happiness than i am mine or yours if you
don't want to pay your part that's okay
but i did book it based on your word
that you were coming yeah and just leave
it like at that and you know just call
their honor out and shame them a little
i would and feel free to bring your own
drinks and then drop it yeah and then
drop it and uh oh by the way it's gonna
be byob for you
exactly
no i'm kidding i'm done just but you
gotta
the thing is
you're a person of uh that that
uh
values honor
and uh it's a big d these kinds of
details are a big deal to you
uh in your personality style and the way
you're wired and your upbringing um
that's not true for everyone
and when you run into people that it's
not you you've got to turn you got to
learn to let them loose because they're
not you're not going to change them
and and you know you're either going to
stir this up and make it a big deal or
you're just going to let it go and it's
not a big deal or the third option is
you can just choose to seethe and you're
going to you're choosing misery when you
do that yeah that's just a
silly way to choose yeah